imagine a world where Farmers plant
seeds with the Precision of a surgeon
welcome to the Modern Age of Agriculture
Once Upon a Time farming meant early
mornings backbreaking labor and a whole
lot of guesswork picture our
grandparents trudging through Fields
using rudimentary tools to sew seeds and
manage crops fast forward to today and
the scene is transformed dramatically
inter Precision farming a technological
Marvel that's changing the game this
isn't just about planting seeds it's
about doing so with meticulous accuracy
precision farming uses advanced
technology like GPS and data analytics
to ensure that every seed has its
perfect place and each drop of nutrient
or pesticide is applied with exact
Precision the results less waste reduced
environmental impact and significantly
higher yields this shift isn't merely a
step forward it's a giant leap Farms are
becoming more sustainable and productive
ensuring that as the global population
grows so does our ability to feed it
efficiently Precision farming isn't just
a fancy concept it's revolutionizing the
way we cultivate our food now Envision
drones soaring above Fields far beyond
just capturing breathtaking views these
high-flying devices are revolutionizing
the way we approach the age-old practice
of Agriculture bringing with them a
future where farming is more precise
efficient and environmentally friendly
in the world of modern agriculture
drones are Not Mere Spectators but
active participants their ability to
hover and maneuver over vast tracks of
land allows them to perform detailed
surveys of crops this aerial perspective
is invaluable by using advanced imaging
technology drones can assess plant
Health detecting issues like nutrient
deficiencies water stress or pest
infestations well before they become
visible to the human eye but the
capabilities of these flying robots
don't stop there equipped with
sophisticated sensors drones can analyze
the moisture content of soil helping
Farmers optimize their water usage this
is particularly crucial in regions where
water is scarce ensuring that not a drop
goes to waste by providing precise
irrigation recommendations drones help
in conserving a vital resource while
boosting crop yields moreover drones are
stepping into roles that were
traditionally labor intensive they can
be outfitted with systems to spray
pesticides and fertilizers targeting
specific areas that need treatment this
not only reduces the amount of chemicals
used but also minimizes the exposure of
workers to potentially harmful
substances the Precision application
ensures that the entire process is more
controlled and less wasteful the
integration of drone technology in
agriculture also brings substantial
economic benefits by automating tasks
such as crop monitoring and spraying
drones reduce the need for manual labor
cutting down on labor costs and allowing
Farmers to manage larger areas with
greater ease this increase in efficiency
can lead to higher productivity and
ultimately greater profitability for
Farmers these flying robots are indeed
becoming indispensable allies for the
modern farmer from optimizing Resource
Management to improving crop health and
reducing environmental impact drones are
at the Forefront of the Agricultural
transformation ensuring sustainability
and efficiency on a global scale who
said plants need soil to grow let's
explore the soilless wonders of
Hydroponics Envision a farming technique
where plants float in water their Roots
bathing in nutrient-rich Solutions
absorbing everything they need to grow
this is Hydroponics a revolutionary
method that doesn't rely on soil instead
plants are supported in systems that
circulate water infused with minerals
and nutrients it's an elegant solution
that turns traditional farming on its
head Hydroponics comes in several
flavors each with its unique setup
there's the wick system quite the
passive player using no pumps or
electricity then there are the more
active systems like the nutrient film
technique where a thin stream of water
constantly flows past the roots or
consider the deep water culture where
plants literally float on water Serene
and efficient but let's add another
layer to this aquaponics a symbiotic
system combining aquaculture and
hydroponics here fish and plants grow
together the waste produced by the fish
supplies nutrients for the plants which
in turn purify the water for the fish
it's a harmonious environment that
mimics Nature's Own Cycles why are these
systems game changers first they they're
incredibly space efficient Hydroponics
allows for dense plantings and can be
stacked vertically making it perfect for
urban settings where space is a premium
imagine skyscrapers with floors
dedicated to Growing greens all without
a speck of soil moreover these methods
are champions of water conservation
hydroponic systems use up to 90% less
water than traditional farming because
water in these systems is recirculated
every drop is utilized reducing waste
and preserving this precious resource
common crops like lettuce tomatoes and
peppers thrive in these systems showing
not only versatility but also
productivity these methods can yield
crops all year round free from the
constraints of seasons and soil quality
Hydroponics and aquaponics are not just
space Savvy they're pivotal for
sustainable Urban farming day or night
these tireless workers Harvest our food
faster than ever before meet the robotic
Harvesters the unsung heroes of modern
agriculture these mechanical marel are
not just transforming the way crops are
harvested they're redefining efficiency
in the farming industry let's delve into
the world of robotic Harvesters these
machines are designed to navigate
through rows of crops with Precision
using Advanced sensors and GPS
technology they can identify right
produce and their robotic arms gently
pick fruits and vegetables ensuring
minimal damage and maximum quality one
of the most significant advantages of
robotic Harvesters is their ability to
work around the clock BL unlike human
labor these robots don't need brakes or
sleep they can continue harvesting
through the night drastically reducing
the time it takes to clear a field this
is particularly crucial during Peak
Harvest Seasons when timing is
everything moreover these robots are
champions of sustainability by
accurately picking only ripe produce and
adjusting their techniques based on the
crop and conditions they significantly
reduce waste this not only ensures that
more of the Harvest makes it from the
field to the table but it also conserves
resources that would otherwise be used
to grow crops that go to waste robotic
Harvesters are also remarkably versatile
they're engineered to operate under
various weather conditions be it under
the scorching sun or amidst a drizzle
this resilience helps maintain a steady
production flow regardless of Mother
Nature's plans the impact of these
robotic Harvesters goes beyond just
technical efficiency they are playing a
pivotal role in addressing some of the
critical challenges facing modern
agriculture such as labor shortages and
the need for sustainable practices by
automating the harvesting process Farms
can produce more with less feeding an
Ever growing global population robotic
Harvesters are setting new standards in
farming ensuring we get fresh produce
anytime anywhere as these machines
continue to evolve they promise not only
to meet but to exceed the demands of the
future making sure that agriculture
remains sustainable and productive these
Technologies might sound straight out of
a Sci-Fi novel but they are very much a
reality and a necessity as we've
explored earlier the landscape of
Agriculture is undergoing a
revolutionary transformation driven by
the integration of Advanced Technologies
like Precision farming drones
Hydroponics and robotic Harvesters each
of these Innovations plays a pivotal
role in shaping a more sustainable
efficient and productive future in
farming let's start with Precision
farming this method uses data and
analytics to make farming more accurate
and controlled Precision far Farming
tools allow Farmers to monitor soil
conditions weather patterns and crop
Health at an incredibly granular level
this means inputs like water fertilizers
and pesticides are applied only where
needed and in the right amounts the
result a significant reduction in waste
lower costs and a smaller environmental
footprint moreover Precision farming
boosts crop yields by ensuring that
crops get exactly what they need when
they need it next consider the role of
drones these flying Marvels are
reshaping how Farmers manage their
fields by providing a bird's eyee view
drones can quickly and efficiently
monitor crop Health across vast areas
detect Pest infestations and even spot
irrigation problems some drones go a
step further equipped to spray
pesticides or fertilizers precisely
where they are needed this not only cuts
down on labor costs but also reduces the
exposure of crops and importantly
Farmers to potentially harmful chemicals
Hydroponics and aquaponics introduce us
to the art of growing plants without
soil these systems use nutrient-rich
water solutions to grow plants which can
be set up anywhere from Urban rooftops
to Desert locals this method is not just
about saving space it's about resource
efficiency hydroponic systems use up to
90% less water than conventional farming
because the water is recirculated the
controlled environment also means fewer
pests and diseases reducing the need for
pesticides and enhancing food safety and
then there are the robotic Harvesters
these machines are designed to pick and
process crops with precision and speed
unmatched by human labor operating
Around the Clock these robots help
farmers Harvest crops at their Peak
condition contributing to higher quality
produce and reduced food waste
additionally robotic Harvesters help
address labor shortages in agriculture a
significant challenge for Farmers Around
The World Together these Technologies
are not just enhancing the way food is
grown they are vital in meeting the
global food demand with the world's
population projected to reach nearly 10
billion by the year 2050 traditional
farming methods alone will not suffice
modern farming Technologies increase the
productivity of the land and decrease
the impact on the environment helping to
feed more people without depleting our
natural resources embracing these modern
farming Technologies isn't just about
staying current it's about ensuring a
sustainable future for all of us as we
continue to face Global challenges like
population growth climate change and
environmental deg gradation these
Innovative farming practices offer hope
and a path forward securing food
security and sustainability